foreign
[Music]
the first Solo movie of the king of
Atlantis was released in 2018 and has
since become the most successful DC film
of all time with box office takings of
1.1 billion US Dollars it quickly became
clear that a second part was to come
after the actual release date was
supposed to be in 2022 fans were again
kept waiting however in December 2023
the time will finally come for Aquaman
and the lost kingdom to hit theaters yet
there are still a few questions about
the project here and there that's why we
sat down for you and compiled everything
important that is known so far after all
some of the statements made by the
producers are quite insightful
in case you don't remember exactly what
the film was about here's a little recap
if you haven't seen the movie yet and
want to avoid spoilers You Should Skip
ahead to the next part of the video
Arthur Curry is born as the son of
Atlanta the queen of Atlantis and Thomas
Curry half human half Atlantean he is
eligible to ascend the Throne of
Atlantis even though he has no interest
in doing so for a long time yet one year
after the event surrounding Justice
League his half-brother orm decides to
unite the six underwater kingdoms and
start a war against the humans who've
been polluting the world's oceans for
decades wanting to stop him Arthur
challenges him in a duel for the crown
which he loses and only barely escapes
with his life he only manages to survive
with the help of the fighter Mira the
two set out to find the Trident of Allen
the first king of Atlantis whose owner
is the ruler of all seas in order to
prevent this orm sets the pirate David
Kane Alias Black Manta on them the
latter has a score to settle with Arthur
since he believes Aquaman to be
responsible for the death of his father
he fails however and so Arthur and Meera
find a wormhole in the depths of the
version of the trench which takes them
to the hidden sea in the center of the
earth there they discover not only the
Trident but also Arthur's mother who is
presumed dead and was sacrificed to the
trench by the atlanteans together with
the Trident and a huge Army of sea
creatures they now face orm and his
hosts this time around Aquaman wins but
spares the life of his half-brother
after he promises to support him upon
learning that his mother is still alive
in the end Atlanta returns to Arthur's
father at the surface while Arthur and
Mira Ascend to the throne
there have constantly been fresh news
about the cast of course we know of many
familiar actors who will again play an
important role but also interesting new
ones are being announced over and over
again among them is someone who is
already considered a terror of the seas
in other series
it's a given that Jason Momoa will once
again take on the role of Arthur Curry
AKA Aquaman he was certainly partly
responsible for the success of the first
movie which clearly stood out from the
otherwise rather weak dceu film
adaptations especially when you see the
portrayals of Aquaman in the comics
Momoa makes a successful change he'll
also be joined by Amber Heard in the
role of Mira for a long time there had
been some uncertainty about her
appearance the trial with her ex-husband
Johnny Depp has lost her some reputation
in Hollywood nevertheless the producers
are giving her a second chance further
confirmed are Nicole Kidman as Queen
Atlanta and Star Wars star Tamara
Morrison as Thomas Curry what kind of
importance the roles will have however
is not yet clear Arthur's half-brother
orm also known as Ocean Master is also
back he will of course be played by
Patrick Wilson again whether he fights
at Aquaman's side or forges his own
plans as something we'll only find out
on the big screen we have also already
seen a villain in the mid-credit scene
of the first part namely Yaya abdulma
team II as David Kane better known as
Black Manta likewise returning his Dolph
Lund is King nerius the father of Mira
atlen the king of Atlantis was
previously introduced as a character but
has been recast he sanked the city
thousands of years ago in an accident
and went into Exile afterwards in the
previous sequences he was played by
Graham McTavish now however Vincent
Reagan is taking over the part we doubt
that he will have a big role we rather
suspect further flashbacks like in the
first part
as we could already see in the
mid-credits scene there is a new villain
namely Dr Steven Shin played by Randall
Park in the scene he pulls the half dead
David Kane out of the sea when Kane
wakes up he's already in Shin's lab Shin
demands to know where Atlantis is and
Promises Black Manta to help him with
his revenge in exchange for the
information this Stephen Shin should not
be too unknown to the comic readers
among you in fact in the comics he is a
friend of Arthur and his father however
it results in a break after the tour
unwilling to reveal anything about
Atlantis to the scientist also to appear
as Carson the tiger shark which mutated
in an atomic explosion and is actually
considered an adversary of Green Lantern
how big the role will be or whether the
villain is only being teased is
unfortunately not yet known the shark is
played by India Moore who is known for
the US series pose
but Arthur Curry won't have to face all
the baddies alone a new hero will also
make his debut we are talking about
Stingray who is a member of the Light
Brigade in the comics the new hero will
be played by Yani Zhao who is still
relatively unknown in Hollywood the
Portuguese actress has previously
appeared mostly in local Productions all
the more reason to look forward to her
debut in Hollywood and her new role in
the dceu
however there is another newcomer we are
most excited about and that is none
other than urine Greyjoy actor pilu
aspack he has already sailed the seas in
Game of Thrones and is known there as a
notorious sailor he is one of the few
actors for whose role not even a name is
known however we hope to see him back in
his old manner namely as a scoundrel and
womanizer he has already demonstrated
that this kind of role suits him well
the appearance of Another Hero is being
heavily discussed and it is none other
than Bruce Wayne Alias Batman will make
an appearance in Aquaman 2. at least
some scenes with the character were shot
with both Ben Affleck and Batman Legend
Michael Keaton the latter was initially
supposed to play him because he will be
brought back via the Multiverse in the
flash which was originally scheduled to
be released first however the movie was
then pushed back to a release date
following the Aquaman sequel due to the
antics of lead actor Ezra Miller as a
result it was then reported that there
had been reshoots of Ben Affleck so as
not to confuse audiences however
according to the latest plans of the DC
EU management The Flash will now be
released before Aquaman 2 again what a
mess Jason Momoa in turn held out the
prospect that perhaps even both Batman
will be featured in the film so it
remains exciting whether in the end none
just one or both Batman actors will be
on screen
already shortly after the release of the
first movie a second one was announced
by DC back in January 2020 the release
date was set for December 2022 with
James Juan directing and David Leslie
Johnson McGoldrick writing the
screenplay even before filming began
there were wild discussions about the
role of Mira Amber Heard was alleged to
a falsified evidence in her trial with
Johnny Depp a petition with 1.6 million
signatures was therefore submitted
pleading for the role to be recast in
the end however the cast remained the
same as in the first part with the
beginning of the pandemic the start of
shooting for Aquaman in the lost kingdom
was also delayed nevertheless the team
managed to complete the film in the
given time but after James Gunn took
over at DC there were many postponements
and cutbacks in upcoming projects to
which many big names fell victim
including Henry Cavill and his role as
Superman as a result Aquaman 2 also had
to be pushed back first to March and
then to December 25th 2023 this also
means that we may have to wait a bit
longer before we get to see the first
trailer for the film
not much is known about the storyline
yet based on the title however we can
make some assumptions about a possible
plot as the title and the lost kingdom
implies a lost kingdom should be the
subject of the story it could be
possible that this very kingdom is not
Atlantis but another kingdom perhaps Dr
Steven Shin stumbled upon it during his
research about the underwater city and
discovered former enemies of Atlantis
together with Kane he can now go in
search of this civilization in order to
bring them back into a war with Atlantis
kalu asback who could potentially lead
the alien Kingdom might also play a
major role according to James Wan
Aquaman 2 will definitely be spookier
than part one the lost kingdom could
possibly be found in the depths of the
trench Kingdom after all that's where
the portal to atlan's Trident was
located it is also conceivable that
Arthur will not be able to fight against
this force on his own and will seek help
from his seemingly reformed brother
should Blackman to be serious about his
revenge it might also be a possibility
that he hunts down Aquaman's father in
this way he would pay Arthur back in
kind since he believes that Arthur is
responsible for his father's death it's
clear that the new threat doesn't just
affect Atlantis but that Aquaman will
have to worry about the fate of many
nations what all this will really look
like is something we will all find out
on December 25th 2023 the excitement is
definitely there already
and well there you have it that's all
the information about Aquaman 2. what do
you think about Ben Affleck's comeback
and which role do you want palu aspect
to play let us know in the comments and
if you don't want to miss any news about
Aquaman until his Premiere don't forget
to subscribe and check out our weekly
movie news
[Music]
foreign